hey youtubers is charlie so AMC just
aired a first look at season 5 of The
Walking Dead they had a whole bunch of
details in the story and interviews on
the set so this is gonna be a breakdown
of all that stuff as well as the new
footage they even had some fun facts
about stuff that happened back in season
4 like that house that Beth and Daryl
went to they had like a whole backstory
for that they got cut out in the script
phase hello to any new people if you're
just finding me for the first time I'm
doing weekly Walking Dead videos while
we wait for season 5 to get here be sure
to subscribe to get everything they
haven't officially said whether or not
it's going to be the middle of October
like it was last year or it's going to
be some other week but it will be in
October that has been confirmed so let's
just go ahead and do a breakdown of that
new footage and then I'll talk about my
top 10 new things that we learned during
the special so the footage isn't an
official trailer it was just a quick 20
seconds of Carol Tyrese and baby Judith
on their way to terminus they were
simultaneously following the railroad
tracks to get determines and trying to
avoid a giant Walker parade it actually
kind of reminded me of that giant parade
that Daryl and me shown ran into when
they first heard the terminus signal in
that charger I can't confirm that it was
the same heard that they ran into the
one that Carolyn tyrese were trying to
avoid but it seems like over the last 16
episodes or so of season 4 we've seen a
mass Walker migration so I'm hoping that
they pay that off sometime in season 5
those walkers that they were hiding from
the clip we're definitely heading
towards terminus yes they walked slowly
but I've seen a few behind the scenes
images of the set where they shoot the
terminus scenes and it looks like
something might be going down so real
quick just careful potential spoilers
for season 5 so if you want to know
anything just skip forward in the video
like 25 seconds so as you can see in
these pictures there's some kind of
giant explosion at terminus I think it
has something to do with the survivors
trying to escape and it also might have
something to do with the Walker parade
reaching terminus I know that doesn't
sound super spoilery I mean obviously
something's gonna blow up eventually it
is walking dead I'm expecting that first
trailer the comic-con one to drop friday
july twenty fifth that's just the day i
think that the Walking Dead panel is
going to be on they haven't announced it
yet officially but since saturday is
Marvel and DC all day in Hall H I just
think they're gonna do like walking dead
and Game of Thrones on Friday I will of
course be doing a mega breakdown video
whenever that comes but now let's talk
about the top ten things that we learned
in this
number 10 terminus is not a trap it's a
test they talked a lot about the conceit
of that unlocked gate at terminus like
why if you're living in this kind of
world with such a huge Chompy threat
walking around why would you leave your
front gate unlocked the simple answer is
that it's a test the people at terminus
are just testing people that come along
to see what they do how they react to
the unlock gate and all the flowers
Scott Gimple pointed out that there were
roof snipers and the terminus people
pretty clearly have been doing whatever
it is they're doing for a long time so
they have the routine down cold I think
the really interesting question here is
is that what are some of the ways that
you can fail that test I mean obviously
Rick failed it because he learned a few
strange things that he probably wasn't
supposed to learn and everyone just
started pulling guns number nine not all
the people at terminus are creepy
cannibals Gimple definitely danced
around the cannibal question he didn't
say flat-out yes or no but he did give
this weird Luke Skywalker stormtrooper
analogy like he said that had Luke been
allowed to go to the Academy in Episode
four like he wanted he would have become
a stormtrooper and worked on the Death
Star just like any other person that
wouldn't necessarily have made him a bad
person it would just made him a person
working for the Empire it would just
have become his reality and he would
have had to go on making decisions using
the same logic heated back on Tatooine
what I think that means is that not all
the people at terminus are going to be
creepy cannibal people it's just that
due to circumstances they find
themselves surviving on the only thing
available they don't believe in what
they're doing in a creepy philosophical
way they're just trying to survive the
bottom line is is that not all the
people at terminus are going to be evil
they're just gonna be victims of
circumstance just like the survivors
number eight the premiere is going to be
explosive I actually kind of took this
in a literal sense I know a lot of you
guys are theorizing that Morgan would
return and somehow save them or Carol
and Tyreese would show up and do
something both are possible and we did
see that Walker parade so that could
also be a factor but I'm not expecting
any of the survivors to escape terminus
right away I do think they're going to
get out of that train car in the first
two episodes and yes you know everyone
inside the train car the survivors are
turning into a pack of wild dogs you
know they're getting backed into a
corner but I don't think getting out of
that train car is going to be just a
physical fight then I'm just going to
barrel out and shoot everyone I think
they might try to use Eugene's cure
they're gonna at least talk their way
out
gene is really good at talking that
mullet is surprisingly disarming lauren
cohan and the producers just kept saying
that the early episodes would be crazy
and then the BLF turn then crazy again
then another left turn I feel like
what's gonna happen is is they're gonna
talk to wear to the train then it's
gonna get crazy they're gonna find out
about all the cannibalism and then Carol
and Tyreese are gonna show up number
seven people that we did not think could
be bad asses are gonna get to be a
badass of all the people in the train
car lauren cohan could have been talking
about i think she was referring to Tara
no matter what happens I just don't
equate Eugene with potential badass Tara
on the other hand is one of those people
who's been like a deer caught in the
headlights she got injured on a way to
terminus and she's been super depressed
about the governor thing I'm really
hoping that she gets to have like a hero
moment in the premier Aisha Tyler was
talking all about the three questions
it's about weeding out the weak people
the ones that don't have the potential
to survive or at least contribute to
everyone's survival Tara seems like
someone who's gonna get there she just
hasn't been pushed over the edge far
enough I think her being in that train
car is going to be that last push over
the edge I really wanted to see her go
crazy on some terminus people that would
be a lot of fun on to number six we will
learn what happened to Beth very quickly
that is to say we will not have to wait
a long time I don't know if she's gonna
be in that first episode but they kind
of implied that she is and more along
the lines of the badass talk I saw a lot
of rumors last year saying that her
character arc this year would be more
about her becoming more of a leader that
definitely fits with lauren cohan comics
that you know people previously not seem
to be badasses will be badasses Beth was
getting pretty mean with Darryl's
crossbow until she got snatched
supposedly she's going to show up
somewhere outside of terminus and it may
or may not be with that new character
that Seth Gilliam is playing the one
that looks like father Gabriel number
five the funeral parlor was not a trap I
love the explanation that it belonged to
this very nice funeral director who was
just cleaning up bodies and bearing them
until one day he just got killed on one
of his runs they cut it out during the
script phase so it was never filmed but
I think that that means that the dogs
that we heard and best kidnapping were
unrelated events no one was using the
house as a trap for terminus or
somewhere else the thing that really
said the rumors off was the fact that
there was so much food there
fully stocked and that just did not
compute with all the other houses that
people have been in that season number
four they're going to be jumping around
with comic book references right now
where they are on the show is right
around where the hunters appear in the
comics but Gimple said this is going to
be doing scenes from way way back in the
comics too so it's not like you can just
go forward one issue of the comic for
each episode that's not really a huge
surprise I mean even when they do
straight-up adaptations like when Rick
bit that guy's neck it wasn't a straight
page to screen adaptation I am really
curious to see what that scene is the
one from way way back it might be a
flashback because they did a ton of
those in season four I think my favorite
flashback last year was whenever
Michonne was flashing back to her life
whenever Andre was still alive number
three rick is going to get vicious
governor style it's been a lot of time
talking about the similarities between
Rick and the governor and made it sound
like if the governor hadn't lost his
daughter Heda made a way better leader
than Rick these should they raised as
that Rick just tries to make too many
decisions based on emotions like he gets
way too emotional he just doesn't have
that creepy calmness that Gareth has
been giving off and now that he's just
bit someone's ear off and killed the
farmer Rick inside of him he's probably
going to get even crazier not like
Looney Tunes crazy but he's going to be
much quicker to violent action number
two terminus will be the biggest threat
that survivors have faced I was actually
surprised when they said that because
the governor in woodbury were a pretty
huge threat in the tank assault last
season was a pretty big deal the
reasoning they provided for that comment
was is that the terminus people just
have a well-oiled machine it's just like
they've been doing what they're doing
with the survivors now many many times
before I just wonder how they're going
to deal with that giant Walker parade
that Carol and Tyreese are bringing I
feel like no amount of roof snipers
would be able to deal with that kind of
horde and my number 1 moment Gareth is
explained Andrew West had this really
cool interview where he spelled Gareth
out pretty clearly he's going to try and
open up the survivors to this new way of
life and try to get them to see what
life can be in this new world that
they're living in and that just sounds
really hippy and new agey in totally
weird what I think that means is is that
yes i still believe he's a cannibal and
he's just going to try and brainwash
everyone in this really subtle way into
thinking that cannibalism is a good idea
yeah like whenever someone you know
that's a vegan tries to convince you
that it's way healthier than not eating
animal protein he's just going to try
and get everyone hyped about the weird
co-op sustainable communities got going
on to terminus I mean it just screams
crazy cult leader brainwashing but now
it's your turn let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
from the special and based on that new
footage what do you think that Carol and
Tyreese are going to do once they get
determinists I mean honestly I think
that they're just going to try and do
the same thing that the walkers back at
the prison do they're going to try and
let the mass on one of the fences just
until it gets torn down so in related
news i will be doing a Q&A for this
video tomorrow be sure to subscribe to
get it you can actually click here to
get all out of the annotation as soon as
I post it and you can click here to
learn about some of the new characters
coming into season 5 thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives